let me show you what I can see they're
using an application of my iPhone
bringing you guys pictures so this is
the cordon philosophy held back now
against the edge of the street which is
an awful lot of activity a number of
injured people
the bums work from the NYPD has attended
out of an abundance of caution that's
the official language because
to show us pictures
there's an awful lot of smoke because
this building might well be a number of
buildings that collapsed actually
according to reports has sent a smoke
into the air face masks to stop the
choking smoke crews working in that area
now under very difficult conditions
we've had reports of eleven people
injured minor injuries at the moment we
know that one person's being treated in
a nearby hospital in an ER in the
emergency room it is expecting that more
victims when you see those pictures from
the air it's hard to believe there are
only eleven minor injuries given the
scale of the response to this incident I
think it gives you a sense of how
seriously the standing by let me just go
on others and officers huddling here in
the corner trying to
handle on how to respond see further up
medicine a number of fire trucks are
waiting in the wings as it were this is
often what happens when there is a major
response that will be a command unit
somewhere in the vicinity although it's
um it's it's hard to know where at the
moment probably the FDNY would have
taken the lead given they were the first
to respond to this incident but if there
is any sense that this happened as a
result of foul play
the police will then will then take the
lead there's a number of people actually
waiting here seeing I think if they can
get back into their Street let me see if
I can have a word with them
excuse me you're live on Sky News are
you waiting to get back into that Street
work nearby reports you know people were
in buildings nearby and heard a huge
explosion with smoke blowing into the
air some people described debris falling
one man even told a local news station
it reminded him of 9/11 because it
wasn't like your typical building fire
there was an explosion and then a fourth
lots of falling debris people were stuck
in their buildings for a while because
it wasn't
runs around this area a hundred and
sixteenth and 450 in Park have been
closed down the rail services in and out
of Grand Central have been closed down
because this explosion happens right
next to the Metro North Wales which is
the main rail service into and out of
northern Manhattan so a huge incident
here an equally large response to
emergency services here in the north of
Manhattan in Harlem area
that's right very often when if there's
an alert incident like this and it's not
clear what's happened and there is a
possibility that something might have
gone wrong when somebody had done it on
purpose for example just an outside
possibility the bomb squad is often
deployed because they don't want to wait
scramble and then be behind the incident
so there is no sense at this was
interesting features the weather
forecast but this is what's occurring
all the time he clearly of still being a
child or this building or ease building
some other people
members
let me show you some of these pictures
up here big emergency response the FDNY
trucks waiting the FDNY ambulance their
emergency paramedics are very often
deployed from the FDNY these are the
guys that responded to 911 and they
trained all the time for things like
this often when I talk to them
response to the big incident ease takes
up an awful lot of the focus of
emergency services in this city and part
of the reason of course is the legacy of
9/11 but also is because this is such a
highly populated city this tiny island
for six million people living on it
actually when something goes wrong the
capacity for lots of people to get hurt
is actually very high and so there is a
huge focus amongst the emergency
services to make sure that everybody is
ready to deploy and respond to those big
incidents involving big buildings and
potentially lots of people as fast as is
humanly possible
it's them it's quite difficult to
breathe even though it's clearing up
this is it's very very smoky this was a
huge huge incidentally